against now reporter Brian will live now
at Reed International with how those
weather patterns really just messed up
some of the the airport delays for the
day today right will
yeah yeah Ted you know like you've been
saying it has been quite windy here but
it wasn't anything that compared how
windy it was earlier today causing
flight disruptions delays and even a
full ground stop here at Reed
International so it wasn't just the
airport that was impacted of course
other areas the wind caused power
outages affecting thousands multiple
street lights were out causing traffic
backups and and a jackknifed semi just
before noon happened on I-15 near lamb
possibly due to those high winds and the
Slick road conditions even the traffic
camera you can see here was shaking
because of those winds and for many
people I spoke to today with that quick
turn of weather events it caught them
off guard
we're from the Northwest originally and
so we're just gonna like yeah we're used
to this stuff
all the things that can delay the
weather here is the wind well between
the weather and the people not figuring
out that it's a four-way stop and
there's no lights that yeah there was a
couple almost bumper to bumper
yeah
he's like thank God you're a good
defensive driver
now the snow cleared up this afternoon
and most of the area went back to normal
Nevada Energy reports of the 15 000
without power most that more than half
has been restored at this point and as
you can see jets are back in the sky
it's a little bit less windy out here
and the Sun is creeping out a little bit
live at Reed International Brian will 8
News Now